entre montagne et campagne le nord-ouest
de la tunisie semble être figé dans un
autre temps les habitants de cette
région considérée comme la plus pauvre
du pays ont souvent l'impression d'être
les grands oubliés du système
à 46 ans ali a perdu tout espoir dans sa
maison de fortune ils tentent tant bien
que mal de subvenir aux besoins de sa
femme et de ses deux enfants
en dépit des multiples promesses de
l'état d'améliorer ses conditions de vie
il semble aujourd'hui ne plus savoir
s'il est toujours tunisien dans un pays
où ses droits les plus élémentaires
semble n'être qu'un mirage des fois j'ai
besoin de ma carte d'identité pour me
souvenir que je suis tunisien
ce n'est qu'une nationalité pour moi car
car si j'étais réellement tunisiens
comme les autres
j'aurai les mêmes droits et moi je n'ai
aucun droit à commencer par le logement
quand je vois que certaines personnes
vivent dans un confort qui ne méritent
pas je vois que dans d'autres régions on
aide beaucoup la population
mais ici personne ne pense à nous et
quand tu vas demander ton du on te dit
qu'il n'y a rien pour le moment personne
ne t'écoute et on te dis simplement que
pour le moment il n'y a rien comment
voulez vous qu'on vivre quand il parle
de sa région
il évoque un bout de territoire qui
n'intéresse les dirigeants qu en période
électorale avant de retomber dans
l'oubli
aussitôt les résultats annoncés toute
l'année personne ne nous considèrent et
quand les élections arrivent ils
débarquent tous avec leurs tracts on te
demande alors de voter et après c'est
fini
retour à la réalité personne ne se
soucie de toi dans ses campagnes c'est
encore à dos d'âne que l'on
s'approvisionnent en eau à travers des
chemins escarpés et boueux en hiver qui
deviennent dangereux avec la neige
il ne faut pas moins de deux heures pour
atteindre la source dans les hauteurs
des montagnes voisines
le dénuement règne manque d'eau et
d'infrastructures de transport ou encore
d'école et pour couronner le tout un
chômage qui grimpe ici à 30% selon
l'institut national des statistiques
j'ai 32 ans et je suis au chômage malgré
le fait que j'allais souvent à tunis
pour trouver du travail
et tu va souvent à tunis toi oui très
souvent j'y vais je cherche du travail
dans les chantiers il n'y a rien il ya
beaucoup de jeunes ici qui sont dans la
même situation
tous on est tous dans la même situation
ces populations vulnérables se
retrouvent très souvent dépourvus en
période d'intempéries ou face à la
maladie malika est né dans la région
quitté son village elle n'y songe pas
une minute
la révolution 2011 avaient suscité chez
elle de grands espoirs
mais dix ans après rien n'a changé
il y a deux ans sa fille de 25 ans a été
emporté par la maladie
en l'absence d'infrastructures médicales
locales
beaucoup décède avant d'atteindre
l'hôpital le plus proche quand ma fille
a eu son attaque
si l'hôpital était proche elle aurait pu
être encore vivante aujourd'hui le temps
de trouver une voiture et de me rendre à
l'hôpital le plus proche
elle était déjà morte j'étais désespéré
et j'ai dû faire demi tour en voiture
avec ma fille morte dans les bras je
n'oublierai jamais ce jour
alors comment expliquer que cette région
pourtant si riche en ressources
naturelles telles que le bois
l'aluminium le zinc ou encore le
phosphate soit en même temps la plus
pauvre du pays
et pourtant la région assure 60 % de la
production céréalière du pays et dispose
de 75 % des réserves d'eau du territoire
depuis tunis ou encore carthage les
politiques ont contribué et contribuent
encore à la paupérisation du nord-ouest
- tirawi et député indépendant de
jendouba le sort de sa région et depuis
toujours sa priorité est face à un
gouvernement qui ne s'intéresse qu'à la
carte électorale
il a parfois le sentiment de mener un
combat perdu d'avancé pas
je pense que tous les gouvernements qui
se sont succédé ont fait l'impasse sur
les régions rurales
malgré le fait qu'on leur rappelle à
chaque fois leurs conditions précaires
le gouvernement ne semble travailler que
pour les intérêts de certaines grandes
familles qui détiennent le pays par leur
mainmise au détriment des populations
qui s'enfonce dans la pauvreté
la tristesse la fatigue et la précarité
en pleine crise politique la tunisie se
retrouve avec plus d'un défi à relever à
commencer par celui des régions rurales
qui se sentent depuis longtemps laissés
pour compte par tunis et qui avait
pourtant fait de grands sacrifices pour
la révolution de 2011 et nourrit
beaucoup d'espoirs dans la démocratie
tunisienne naissante